♫ Ahh
♫ Ahh♫
- Okay, who's going second?
- I'll go second.
- Okay. Alright
- Wait, go.
Okay wait. Millie. Wait, wait, start over.
- Sorry.
- Okay you're go.
(laughing)
(electronic music)
- Can you hand me the pink icing?
- Well, I'm using it at the moment.
- You know what Millie?
- I think we became friends
when we started that group chat.
And just when we started shooting.
We just started having
a great time on camera.
And it just like, we just had fun
and we just became friends
right away, you know?
- Scenes where I have to be serious
and then Gaten makes you laugh.
Those are the--
- I used to do that a lot.
- Yeah, you still do it.
- Yeah, watch out for next season, guys.
- Probably the school scene when we..
When I was like, you know, dying.
Which was really fun.
(laughing)
- Oh that was kind of fun, yeah.
- In a way, cause like, Gaten
got to carry me and then--
- I did.
- I didn't have to walk.
- I'm like Superman.
I had an injured ankle and
an injured knee that day.
Same leg.
And Finn couldn't carry Millie.
- Obviously.
- He couldn't carry her.
And I had to carry her, which
was pretty funny actually.
- Finn's a weakling.
(Gaten laughs)
Sorry.
Sorry Finn.
- We're so mean to Finn.
- Yeah.
- Who's more.. Oh, Gaten.
- Me.
- Dustin.
- Totally.
- I mean Gaten.
Gaten's the most like his character.
(Gaten laughs)
- [Gaten] Caleb.
- Me.
- That guy right there.
- I couldn't stop laughing.
I had a problem.
A laughing problem.
- When they made me laugh,
I'd have to cut for break, it's too much.
So I'd have to like, I'd have to go and--
- And we made you laugh a lot.
- Made me laugh all the time.
But then I think I was the serious one.
- Yeah she was.
- I'd tell them to stop.
- She would tell us to
shut up and we would.
Cause she scares us.
- And I would be like
I'm sorry Millie, you
wanna be friends again?
(laughs)
- Be like, no!
- [All] Yes.
- We would just sing on set for no reason.
- Really just harmonize--
- [Caleb and Millie] Out of nowhere.
- Ready?
♫ Ahh
♫ Ahh ♫
(laughing)
- What was that?
- That was awesome guys.
- Okay, so mine is basically like Eleven.
She's a hot mess.
And that's it, that's it right there.
There you go.
- This is a loose Lucas
Sinclair dish, right.
You got your gummy worms,
he loves gummy worms.
- It's very organized.
- No, yeah very organized, yeah.
Lucas is very picky, you know?
- Great, okay what I
have here, I don't know.
But I think it looks awesome.
- I'm gonna try mine, why not?
- [Caleb] Food's free.
- Wow it tastes disgusting.
- [Gaten] Well, yeah,
cause you put so much
of that food spray on there.
- Oh, it actually doesn't taste too bad.
- Thank you guys, so much.